so once I found out there was a sex
robot Factory I obviously had to go
here's why I went to the sex robot
Factory I am fascinated by the question
is this impossible standard of beauty
that women are killing themselves to try
to achieve is that even what all men
want
I'm delighted to report back that the
answer is no not only did half of the
dolls that were ordered have pubic hair
the customers spent an extra fourteen
hundred dollars for it ice fourteen
hundred dollars getting mine lasered off
this is proof we are not communicating
we got to start talking to each other
you guys it will save us money
but that wasn't enough I still wanted to
see what they were doing with the robot
bodies what if they were making these
impossible to achieve by that'd be bad
for society right I especially wanted to
see the boobs because in my head every
guy wants the same kind of boot right
giant Double D little tiny perky nipple
no no
there's a wall of nipples 38 different
kinds one of the most popular I'm long
one of them looked like a piece of
caramel fell on the floor bestseller
great news ladies whatever shape your
nipple there is a man out there who will
pay top dollar
so I found this fascinating and I
started talking to the guy who puts the
nipples on the robots right it takes him
24 hours to put on one pair of nipples
I'm like what's the problem Mr Potato
had that shit let's go
and he said it's actually a very
meticulous process because they work
very hard to make sure the nipples are
uneven because for something to look
human it has to have flaws if something
is too symmetrical it actually looks
creepy take that Ryan Gosling's face
that was great news for me and you guys
might know why some of you might not
know this but I had Eating Disorders
until I was in my late 20s and as a
result my boobs grew in different sizes
that's a side effect for people when
they have Eating Disorders sometimes
does your boobs grow in a little bit
differently I had to get three surgeries
to get them straightened out one was
bigger than the other one one was higher
than the other one they
they look like from the same general
family one was just like a shittier
version of the other one it was like
Alec Baldwin and Stephen Baldwin
I kind of just wanted to Stevens you
know
or to Alex I'll take either at this
point
and I was always so embarrassed about
them because before I'd get with a guy I
felt like I had to explain what he was
about to see I'd have to prepare him you
know I'd be like do you like baseball
and golf
do you like young women nand old men
you don't have to choose
big Salvador Dali fan
so the tragic irony of this whole thing
is that they're still not even because
one of the surgeons made a mistake and
they cut through a muscle
I know never get an operation by the
airport
red flag I feel like I probably should
have saw
and I hated them for the last couple
years I hated them because I felt
ashamed my whole thing is you know
accept who you are love your body and I
felt like a hypocrite because I had
these implants in so I resented having
all that work done for the longest time
until a couple years ago when I got in a
really bad snowboarding accident and I
broke my shoulder and I go into the
surgeon and he's like I don't understand
this injury makes no sense I see this
all the time when people fall forward on
a snowboard they break their nose they
get a concussion you only broke your
shoulder how did this happen
and in that moment I realized
that I bounced off my tits
[Applause]